han sido dos días muy ajetreados para
esta clínica abortista de houston pero
el aumento de las visitas ha durado poco
el viernes un tribunal federal de
apelaciones de eeuu dictaminó que texas
podría restaurar la prohibición de la
mayoría de las interrupciones
voluntarias del embarazo menos de 48
horas después de que otro tribunal
suspendiera tal prohibición la medida no
tardó en suscitar críticas entre los
activistas esta es una orden
profundamente alarmante que permitirá
que la prohibición del aborto en texas
vuelva a entrar en vigor en un momento
en que los proveedores de abortos
estaban comenzando rápidamente a
reanudar la atención al aborto para
todas las pacientes la ley del aborto en
texas entró en vigor el 1 de septiembre
prohíbe el procedimiento a partir de las
6 semanas de embarazo y no hace
excepciones para las víctimas de
violación o incesto la norma también
permite a los ciudadanos hacer cumplir
la prohibición
recompensando les con hasta 10.000
dólares por demandar a cualquiera que
ayude a facilitar los abortos ilegales
el miércoles por la noche a un juez del
distrito de eeuu suspendió la
restricción lo que hizo que las clínicas
de texas reanudarán los abortos
esto fue anulado el viernes tras una
apelación del fiscal general del estado
que en paxton se dirigió a twitter poco
después de la decisión calificándola de
gran noticia y prometiendo luchar contra
la extralimitación federal el gobierno
de bailén que presentó el recurso contra
la ley de texas tiene hasta el martes
para responder